well the problem is good journalism
doesn't get clicks right it's about
pumping up the base or whatever and that
works both ways by the way we've seen
this uh you know I hate to make this
point here in the heart of liberalism
but um you know if you look at I was a
stand-up comedian in 2016 I believed all
the stuff we were being told about
Donald Trump I used to have a joke I'm
from Russia they say Russians don't
understand democracy got Trump elected
didn't we
right and guess
what which we what that that wasn't true
right there is some truth in that but
that that wasn't really what happened
look at the pandemic how many lies were
we told about the pandemic Mass work
they don't work China where does the
where did the virus come from so I think
the truth is both uh sides of the media
Spectrum have gone into this kind of
sensationalism and they're not doing
good journalism because good journalism
is
boring
yeah